do you enjoy doing this kind of thing
where you break things down and and give
your perspective on things and try to
illuminate certain complex subjects i'm
not trying to illuminate so much as
you know talking to i learn as much as i
say and i learn it for myself because
i'm being forced to articulate it right
i can sit around and think my thoughts
all day long but it's a lot of it's
going to be nonsense it's not i'm going
to because there are gaps in thinking
where you make leaps because you're kind
to yourself that you don't realize
you're making but when you're forced to
write it down and this is why i tweet or
when you have to talk to somebody you
have to complete those gaps and make it
a proper logical chain
and the mistake that i made when i was
young was you know i always wanted to
seem like the smartest kid in the room
uh you know like just like you probably
want to seem like the funniest kid in
the room or the toughest kid in the room
right we're all losers starting out we
want to be winners so we pick the thing
we're good at and we double down on it
so i always want to be the smartest kid
in the room so what did i do i read a
lot of books i memorized a lot of things
and then whatever i hadn't memorized is
pre-google i made it up so it sounded
good okay
pre-google after google fact checking
started and i had to get better right so
google improved me that way a lot of
people exactly so
now what i realized is that the biggest
mistake was memorization right because
when you're actually trying to live your
life in congress with reality
you
you want to have a deep understanding of
what you do and why you do it and so
it's much more important to know the
basics really well then is to know the
advanced knowing calculus wouldn't help
you today it doesn't help you in
business doesn't help you in most things
but knowing arithmetic really will help
you really whether it's at the corner
grocery store counting change to
figuring out the value of your podcast
business to figuring out how to do the
probability math on you know some action
that you want to take so understanding
basic mathematics cold is way more
important than memorizing calculus
concepts
and the problem is and this is true of i
think all reasoning it's much better to
know the basics from the ground up solid
foundation of understanding a steel
frame of understanding than it is to
just have a scaffolding which is
memorizing advanced concepts this is why
there are a lot of people i'm sure that
you listen to who are really smart they
use a lot of jargon and you can't quite
follow their reasoning you don't know
how they're putting things together and
this deep down suspicion they don't even
really understand right
so if you look at the the most powerful
thinkers especially the ones where money
or life is on the line
they have to understand the basics
really really well richard feynman the
physicist was able to
he had this piece in one of his lectures
where he takes you from counting numbers
on your hand all the way to calculus in
four pages of text orally but written
down to four pages of text and it's a
complete unbroken logical chain that
takes you through geometry trigonometry
pre-calculus analytic geometry graphs
everything all the way to calculus he
understood numbers at a core level he
didn't have to memorize anything when
you're memorizing it's an indication
that you don't understand
you should be able to rederive anything
on the spot
and if you can't you don't know it
so do you apply that to
things other than mathematics and apply
it to everything everything you don't
even make attempt to memorize things
just make an attempt to understand them
you can't help but memorize things right
if you can't and this is where twitter
is great for me is i try to understand
something and then i try to write it
down in such a way that i can remember
it just the basic hook that'll point
towards the deeper understanding and i'm
forced to explain it to people and
that's how i know i understand something
so this is what i meant originally we
talked about reading
a good book i'll read one page in a
night and then i spend the rest of the
night thinking about it or i'm chasing
down references on wikipedia or weird
blog posts trying to understand it can
you uh then zoom back in to specific
problems with starship or any
engineering problems you work on
can you try to introspect your
particular biological neural network
your thinking process and describe how
you think
through problems the different
engineering and design problems is there
like a systematic process you've spoken
about first principles thinking but is
there kind of absolutely process to it
well um
yeah i like saying like like physics is
low and everything else is a
recommendation
um like i've met a lot of people who can
break the law but i haven't met anyone
who could break physics
so
uh so first for you know any kind of
technology problem you have to sort of
just make sure you're not
violating
physics
and
you know
first principles analysis i think is
something that can be applied to
really any walk of life uh any anything
really it's just it's it's really just
saying um
you know let's let's well something down
to the most fundamental uh
principles the things that we are most
confident are true at a foundational
level
and that sets you at your sets your
axiomatic base and then you reason up
from there and then you cross check your
conclusion against the the axiomatic
truths
so
um you know some basics in physics would
be like are you violating conservation
of energy or momentum or something like
that you know then you you're it's not
gonna work
so what will often happen in trying to
design a product is because people will
start with the tools and and parts and
methods that they are familiar with
and then
and try to create the product using
their existing tools and methods
the other way to think about it is
actually imagine the try to imagine the
platonic ideal of the perfect
product or technology whatever it might
be
and so what is this what is the perfect
arrangement of atoms
that would be the best possible product
and now let us try to figure out how to
get the atoms in that shape
i mean it's it sounds um
it's almost like a rick and morty absurd
until you start to really think about it
and
you really should
think about it in this way because yeah
everything else is kind of uh
if you think uh
you you might fall victim to the
momentum of the way things are done in
the past unless you think in this way
well just as a function of inertia
people will
want to use the same tools and methods
that they are familiar with
um
they just that's what they'll do by
default yeah and then that that will
lead to an outcome of things that can be
made with those tools and methods but it
is unlikely to be the um platonic idea
of the perfect product
um
so
then so that's why it's good to think of
things in both directions they're like
what can we build with the tools that we
have but then but but also what is the
what is the perfect the theoretical
perfect product look like and and that
that theoretical perfect product is
going to be a moving target because as
you learn more
the
definition of or or for that perfect
product will change because you don't
actually know what the perfect product
is but you can successfully approximate
a a more perfect product
so the thing about it like that and then
saying okay now what tools methods
materials whatever do we need to
create in order to get the atoms in that
shape
but people ver
rarely think about it that way
but it's a powerful tool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you